j'ai tenu à me rendre pour mon premier
déplacement de ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse ici à La
Verrière dans un établissement qui a été
touché détruit par les émeutes qui sont
survenus dans notre pays au début du
mois et donc c'était important pour moi
d'être au côté des personnels des
directrices évidemment des élus locaux
qui ont été particulièrement
traumatisées par ceux qui sait passer ça
a été des scènes ça m'a été décrit à
l'instant des meudes de désolation
l'espoir c'est évidemment les solutions
qui vont être trouvées à très court
terme pour les élèves évidemment les
chantiers de reconstruction qui vont
pouvoir démarrer je rappelle qu'un
projet de loi qui permet d'accélérer
drastiquement toutes les procédures de
travaux de reconstruction vient d'être
adopté par le Parlement après avoir été
adopté à l'unanimité au Sénat et je
salue à nouveau son président en tout
cas je veux vraiment merci pour la très
forte mobilisation du maire Nicolas
Dainville du département de Pierre Bédié
de la région
Île-de-France avec Valérie Pécresse pour
trouver des solutions et je me dans un
instant elle établissement à l'école
régionale du 1er degré qui va permettre
d'accueillir les élèves qui étaient ce
que les scolarisés dans ces
établissements tous les élèves auront
une solution de scolarisation pour la
rentrée mais moi ce qui m'importe c'est
que cette solution soit viable
évidemment la consigne que je donne à
mes services c'est de se placer toujours
du point de vue de l'élève et de sa
famille parce que du point de vue du
ministère on peut se dire il y a une
solution de scolarisation qui a été
proposée enfin si elle est à une
demi-heure à pied il y a une question de
transport qui se pose si la cantine n'a
pas la même tarification que dans
l'établissement d'origine c'est
évidemment un impact pour les familles
donc tout ça va être regardé au
millimètre près pour trouver les
solutions viables il y aura un point de
contact tous l'été pour les élus et les
personnels éducatifs au sein de mon
ministère et la mobilisation sera absol